castmates on the Big Bang Theory have
told me that you they get a TV a hard
time yes when you're not around they say
things behind your back and they've said
that you love making mirror face pop
let's talk about that is that true you
like to make mirror face I don't I mean
I don't like to do it it's just when you
look in the mirror doesn't your face
change a bit like don't you like you
guys don't do that yes you do that like
when you're looking in the mirror you
yeah that's like a nice this is nice you
know you want to look good you guys
don't do that I'm not even making a joke
I'm serious like yeah just like do that
stuff so I look at the mirror I was like
I always do the same thing I start to
fall in love with myself and then I do
this with my hair Wow proving it's fake
that's amazing
what how do you do that I better do this
Andy can you do that well Andy your
eyebrows are just going up and down I've
never tried it
okay this is why I can't read all that
time went into developing this as a
driver my Scout muscle a very powerful
Scout you're very fastidious that's
[Laughter]
you